I always said that I'm condita from
living single but I'm also Miranda from
Sex in the City and I look at Tracy
Ellis Ross is one of the original opera
black girls do any of you have a
completely unremarkable friend or maybe
a houseplant I can go to dinner with on
a Saturday night I feel like that's Sex
in the City Miranda yes
don't let this product fool you is that
one single damn it damn it I used to
think people who sat alone at Starbucks
riding on their laptop for pretentious
poseurs now I know they are people who
have recently moved in with someone
behind you first on Sex in the City
Carrie mmm-hmm we embrace our big
booties and we move on gotta be
girlfriend he looked the same he smelled
the same the next thing I knew he kissed
me and my clothes fell off that
girlfriend
jeez if you don't your tear ducts will
get blocked up and then when you get old
you won't be able to cry I know this
isn't girlfriend
sexy is what I try to get them to see me
as after I win them over with my
personality my girl Miranda keep them in
the dark until they mature into
something we wouldn't mind having dinner
with what I'm gonna guess living single
oh yes you just don't know what it takes
to be this stunning girlfriend I don't
know I can't be bothered with her little
drama I'm pregnant and I'm hungry oh god
I'm feeling sorry my ugly sex is hot
some of the best sex I've had is with
people I can't stand is that second city
oh you can tell what I've watched
recently and what I have watched me